threads is a brand new platform launched
by meta who now owns Facebook and
Instagram and threads it's clearly a
direct copy to Twitter Twitter's already
launched a lawsuit against meta in
regards to this but nevertheless the
growth is incredibly fast and minimum I
would suggest that you sign up for
Threads and secure your handle if you
already have an Instagram you just go
into your app store download the threads
app and then they pretty much link up a
tip for any social media platform secure
your handle on the platforms you're not
even active on because who knows someday
you may want to be active there and
fortune favors the fast